hello welcome to rayleigh windmill
we're going to talk about some items
today that we've got on the museum floor
which is on the first floor of the
windmill the first item we're going to
talk about is the coal saver
and this was a small metal object which
you should be able to see a picture of
now
this object was placed into a fireplace
and the coal was put around it
when the fire was lit the coal saver
used to heat up and let out quite a bit
of heat therefore saving the use of coal
next item we're going to look at is a
hot water bottle
these are made of earthenware or
stoneware this particular one which you
can see a picture of now
would have been placed into your bed on
a cold day to warm up the sheets
and they were really nice to put your
feet on to keep them nice and warm
and the third item we're looking at is a
toaster thought to date back to the
1940s or 50s
you should see a picture now with the
open and closed the downside of this
toaster was that you had to put the
toast in
open it and then turn it round to cook
the other side
when we reopen the windmill come and
visit us and come up to the first floor
and visit the museum
there's lots of interesting items
concerning local history from rayleigh
including items from the first world war
the second world war
and lots more see you soon
you